If you're like many music fans,...
…the soundtrack of your life overlaps with the soundtrack to Grease,...
…whether you're in your 70s or your teens.
Many of those timeless songs were sung by Olivia Newton-John.
So, what better way to honor her than by singing too?
Like this a cappella version of "Hopelessly Devoted to You"...
...by 28-year-old country star, Kelsea Ballerini.
Same ballad posted by Julianne Hough,..
…who played Sandy in Grease Live back in 2016.
She writes, "Like so many, Olivia has always been my hero".
Kristin Chenoweth shared her rendition from the TV show "Pushing Daisies,"...
…along with a message, "For Olivia. I love you."
"You were everything to me."
And fellow Australian superstars Nicole Kidman and Keith Urban wrote,...
"Livvie brought the most divine light into the world.
We will always be hopelessly devoted to you."
It's a sentiment echoed across the globe,...
…from Australia, where landmarks turned pink in her honor,...
...to Hollywood, where fans left flowers on her Walk of Fame star.
My mom was scared to even tell me the news this morning...
…because she knew I'd cry like a baby, and I did.